plus on a more serious note because this
has been the part unofficially of http
protocol it is possible that
a lot of services might break if this is
removed from the spec right there's a
status code in http which is 400 418 i'm
a teapot now why does that exist why
this is important let's figure out in
this video also if you are new to the
channel make sure you subscribe and like
the video to receive daily updates on
programming content released on kodam
this video is a part of code dam's
t-shirt giveaway program for the month
if you want to take part and win an
amazing go damn t-shirt all you have to
do is leave a comment on this video
about what you think and that's it you
are eligible if your comment gets a
heart from code damn you will win a
t-shirt for absolutely free before
actually getting to 418 let's first of
all look at what http status codes are
right so http is a protocol we have
discussed a bit about this in the rest
versus graphql video which you can find
somewhere as a card in the description
but what http status codes are they are
a collection of numbers which are also
not you know continuous in nature so
there could be just a few numbers in a
certain range so let's start with
100 range so 1xx stands for any number
which starts with one any status quo
which starts with one and then has two
digits right so
this
right here this range right here is for
informational responses as the mdn dock
says and to be honest i have not seen
any any sort of use case of 1xx
except for status code 101 which is used
when you upgrade a websocket connection
to websocket connection that is you have
an http connection and that gets
upgraded to a websocket connection which
again which we discussed in our
websocket versus http video again you
can find somewhere the link for that
then we have a range of 200 where the
most common one are probably on the
internet is status code 200
okay which is basically saying that
whatever you did the request the
operation was successful on the server
right this is probably the most common
status return code on the internet right
now there are a few more codes in this
range for example the 204
return code means that there was no
content returned from the server so it's
just a
just a confirmation that whatever you
want does not has a content and this is
mostly used with caching updates so
updating the header cache and stuff like
this and you also have 206 as the status
update which is partial content and this
is very very useful when you are for
example
watching a video right streaming a video
whatever you're doing so you don't
want the server to return the full video
in the single response because that will
be heavy and you would lose the ability
to seek the video right and download
selectively the part of that so there
the server returns 206 as the code then
in the range of 300 we have the
redirection messages which is basically
saying that hey to the client that hey i
want you to not go to this url which
you're trying but try some other url
right so three zero one three zero two
these are temporary permanent redirect
status codes three zero seven and eight
as well so
there are a bunch of status quotes
obviously missing in in this range as
well and this range as well and you can
see that pretty much whole range is
unused right you would probably have
five or ten more status codes in two 200
range and similarly for 300 means right
so it's not about it's not about making
use of all the numbers because if that
was then we'll probably just write all
the status quo in the
100 range but it's more about this digit
right here right and the purpose it
serves if there's any use case where we
would want a new redirection message to
happen that will go in the 300 range not
in 200 or not 100 range then we have
finally have the 400 range which is the
client errors now this client did
something bad whether it's
unauthorization or you know not allowed
or whatever and then we have the 500
range which is the server error that
means server
messed up that server crashed or server
is down or whatever so these are all the
ranges we don't have a 600 range at
least not
right now so we have a status code
called 418 in this range right and if we
take a look at some of the other status
codes in this range we start with 400 as
bad request 401 as unauthorized 403
forbidden 404 not found and so on right
so you can see that these are
client-based errors and probably the
names of mr roberts episodes as well but
what you would see is that we have a
four one hundred eight four one eight as
the status code which says i'm a teapot
right so
this is this technically is not
the part of the specification right so
if you actually go and look in the
specification you will not see that http
has to implement a 418 status code but
this was implemented as a joke so in the
month of april
1998 the ietf community which
creates these all these status quo and
stuff which created this stuff actually
proposed as a joke on first april that
we should have a 418 as a status code
for responding as i am a teapot for
anything which is brewing a coffee right
so it's it's basically
more or less a joke uh which was
implemented which was not even
implemented as a specification at that
time but has been the running joke for a
long time if you want to see it for
yourself you can go to
google.com slash teapot and google
actually has a dedicated page which
turns the status code of 418 and if you
right click inspect element and see in
the network tab and in the request
section you will see that the status
code return is actually 480 in fact a
lot of frameworks and runtimes like
node.js and golang as well for example
actually allow you to return 418 as a
standard status code right so you could
technically return 418 from other
languages but that might not be
standardized node.js golang and a few
more i think also implement this as a
standard http return code in express you
can technically say rest dot
send cold or i don't know what the
syntax is press js and this and this
will actually set the code as 418 cent
code or status code whatever the call is
right if you go to this website say
418.com and see the struggle people had
with node.js golang and these sort of
you know frameworks and runtimes in
order to save 418 from being removed is
actually funny and a bit interesting as
well that developers want the status
code to be made as an official http
status code as well and i do believe
like it's a it's a fun thing to have in
the spec itself whether or not you know
it does not make any technical sense as
per say but it has been part of the
history for so long that it does not
make sense remove it from the web plus
on a more serious note because this has
been the part unofficially of http
protocol it is possible that a lot of
services might break if this is removed
from the spec right so yeah i mean it's
good for everyone i think if we just
make 418 as an official http status code
but i would love to know your opinion on
what do you think about this have you
ever tried to return a 418 and if not
would you try to do it right now once
this video ends in one of your rest api
endpoints as an easter egg because that
is that is a cool easter egg right so
yeah that's pretty much it for this
video if you enjoyed it make sure you
leave a like and hit the subscribe
button thank you all for watching and
i'm gonna see you in the next one really
soon
[Music]
[Music]
you